la question est ce que le nouvel iPhone
14 pro Max est une GoPro oui bah
forcément on a un nouveau mode action
cam est-ce qu'il fonctionne réellement
est-ce que par rapport à une GoPro 11
black il fera le taf il le fera pas
est-ce que cet iPhone 14 pro Max a de
bons fichiers ROR est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment l'utiliser pour faire de la
photo professionnelle est-ce que ce
nouveau capteur 48 mégapixels sur
l'iPhone 4 pro max et bon pour les
photos de nuit pour faire du pixel
binding 4 pixel en 1 c'est une techno
qu'on connaissez déjà avant mais qui
vient d'arriver ici sur les iPhones bref
est-ce que cet iPhone 14 pro max est un
bon smartphone oui ou non on va regarder
plein de choses sur la photo pas que la
photo vous allez voir la vidéo également
mais tout plein d'intégration logiciel
et je compte sur vous pour me dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas dans les
commentaires allez on y va
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec rhinoshield
parce que je vous le dis je vous le
redis une fois de plus avoir un bel
iPhone c'est bien mais il faut penser à
venir le protéger et pour venir le
protéger et bien vous avez les coques de
mon partenaire rhinoshield chérie vous
en avez pour tous les produits les
iPhone 14 mais également les iPhone 13
votre APPLE watch Série 7 c'est réduite
vos airpods mais également plein de
produits sur Android et
exceptionnellement à l'occasion la
sortie des iPhone 14 vous avez -15% de
remise via le lien que je vous mets en
bas dans la description il faudra saisir
également le code gre22
grr22 à noter que les produits sont
compatibles maxave pour les séries 12 13
et 14 vous allez pouvoir avoir le grip
max une solide suites une clear c'est
une coque transparente ou encore un mode
NX justement sur le modélix vous allez
avoir un Verseau qui est interchangeable
vous allez donc pouvoir venir customiser
votre iPhone à votre guise la solide
suite c'est une coque complète qui va
venir protéger votre iPhone de tous les
côtés la clé c'est une coque
transparente que je trouve hyper canon
et vous avez le Greep Max qui est une
poignée de prise en main ferme et qui
fera également office de support
téléphone mes chéris aussi vous aussi la
possibilité de dire customiser votre
iPhone avec différentes collaborations
que ce soit Marvel League of Legends
Lord of the Rings Star Wars Game of
Thrones vous en avez des tonnes de tous
les côtés regardez par exemple ici sur
One Piece vous avez des créations qui
sont vraiment super belles donc si vous
aimez l'univers One Piece vous pouvez y
aller les yeux fermés et c'est également
le cas pour des tonnes de collaboration
une fois de plus vous renvoie au lien en
bas dans la description autre option qui
est géniale vous pouvez faire imprimer
directement vos photos sur votre coque
et pourquoi pas graver vos initiales une
fois de plus n'oubliez pas vous avez
encore 15% avec le code gros 22 vous
cliquez sur le lien en bas dans la
description comme ça vous allez pouvoir
venir protéger votre iPhone dans les
meilleures conditions et merci à
rhinoshield d'avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo je voudrais d'abord qu'on parle de
quelque chose qui nous saute aux yeux
c'est cette nouveauté dynamic Island
dynamic Island le nom est peut-être très
bon en anglais mais c'est vrai qu'en
France c'est un peu bizarre alors on
comprend le concept l'idée c'est de
venir modifier un peu l'encoche sans
réellement la modifier mais là où Apple
extrêmement malin c'est qu'il vient
créer des usages si par exemple je viens
mettre un casque comme ça avec mon
casque via se connecter bien vous voyez
j'ai mon casque ici alors par exemple
j'ai mon casque et de la même manière
j'en sais rien je vais mettre un petit
minuteur 20 minutes je le mets et au
timer en haut genre mon casque la même
manière et si je décide de mettre de la
musique voyez je me mets de la musique
et là je vais avoir en même temps ma
musique je vais avoir mon timer bref
j'ai tout qui est là et je trouve ça
assez malin parce que j'appuie sur le
timer je récupère le timer je sors de là
j'appuie ici je récupère ma musique et
si je fais un petit appui hop là juste
comme ça je le récupère comme ça donc je
trouve que le truc et franchement assez
malin c'est bien pensé c'est bien vu et
c'est bien optimisé ici de la part
d'Apple est-ce que pour autant c'est la
meilleure intégration qu'on puisse avoir
aujourd'hui alors sur un iPhone oui
c'est clair c'est très très clair mais
par rapport à ce qu'on connaît des
smartphones Android bon on se dit que
c'est bien c'est une évolution en tout
cas Apple continue à avancer et on se
demande quel sera la prochaine évolution
et si on continue à garder face ID donc
on vient de déverrouiller de façon
complètement sécurisé et ça c'est plutôt
chouette ou est-ce qu'ils nous
emmèneront plus tard allez le savoir
est-ce qu'en tout cas c'est bien réussi
sur les iPhone pro cette année la
réponse est oui c'est une évolution même
s'il y a pas de truc complètement fou
mais c'est très malin en tout cas d'un
point de vue logiciel autre sujet ici
qui moi m'intéresse c'est la partie de
l'écran on a toujours ici une très belle
dame un très bel écran encore plus
lumineux que ce qu'on avait avant donc
lorsque vous allez dehors qui fait
boursement il fait pas très beau mais si
il se met à faire beau bien vous aurez
la luminosité c'est cool c'est le
premier point et le deuxième point et
bien c'est le always on display et moi
seul voisin display au début ça me
perturbait parce que j'imagine mon
iPhone n'est pas éteint alors j'appuyé
pour l'éteindre ah bah non en fait il
était éteint ce qui est très marrant en
fait c'est que always on display ici il
est quand même assez lumineux on voit
plein de choses alors que sur certains
smartphones androïde c'est juste l'heure
c'est noir il y a pas grand chose ici
vous avez plus d'éléments on va
retrouver des éléments de couleur même
si effectivement la luminosité est très
basse mais néanmoins elles sont présents
donc il y a un truc un petit peu zarby
je me dis j'arrive pas à couper mon
téléphone et c'est vrai que par rapport
à un iPhone 13 pro max que j'ai pendant
longtemps c'était très bizarre est-ce
qu'on s'y habitue la réponse est oui
maintenant il y a un truc que j'ai
remarqué au début mais qui maintenant va
beaucoup mieux c'est-à-dire que sur les
premiers jours d'utilisation je trouvais
que l'autonomie était vraiment pas
terrible je te l'ai même pas une journée
je dis mais qu'est-ce qui se passe j'en
ai pas un usage de dingue ça va mieux ça
s'améliorer je remonte à ce que j'avais
avant et mon iphone 13 pro max c'est à
dire une journée et demie presque deux
jours pas vraiment de jour mais presque
2 jours avec un usage normal un usage
qui est le mien donc j'arrive à
l'emmener suffisamment loin donc
l'autonomie me semble pas être
particulièrement impacté par le always
on display ici que vous dire maintenant
sur la partie performance alors ça on
est sur téléphone on a effectivement ici
la nouvelle puce la A16 bionique qui
fonctionne vachement bien beaucoup de
performances il faut qu'on ait tout le
travail que fait Apple ici ils ont très
bien réussi leur puce ça marche ça
fonctionne bien je voudrais maintenant
qu'on parle d'un élément essentiel qui
est un peu la valeur forte aujourd'hui
de ces iPhones et bien c'est toute la
partie photo vidéo avec notamment je dis
bien notamment ce capteur de 48
mégapixels et pour ce faire on va venir
regarder ce qu'on peut faire avec on va
commencer par ce qui est plus facile à
faire pour un smartphone c'est à dire
les photos de jour on a une belle
luminosité il y a de la lumière ou la
cape on va surtout travers du capteur et
ça va c'est facile alors ici sans grande
surprise de l'iPhone s'en sort bien s'en
sort très bien on sent toujours une
petite teinte colorimétrique propre à
l'iPhone mais qui fonctionnera aussi sur
grand angle ultra grand-angle que vous
avancez dans votre image tout en sachant
qu'ici il y a un truc qui est assez
intéressant c'est que vous avez
effectivement un zoom x 2 qui va être
numérique en fait on va venir zoomer ici
dans votre capteur principal dans votre
48 mégapixels on va dire choper au
centre de l'image ok on a un X 3 optique
donc en fait le jeu se ressemble un
petit peu la voyage sur le grand angle
je passe sur l'ultra grand-angle et une
vraie cohérence colorimétrique et ça
fonctionne je vais ensuite sur le X 2 je
passe ensuite sur le X 3 et
[Musique]
que je trouve un peu dommage franchement
c'est que regarder là ce bazar que ça
met il y a un travail optique à venir
faire encore ici pour venir corriger ces
choses là qu'on devrait pas avoir sur ce
smartphone le plus haut de gamme le
smartphone que m'a passé Apple c'est un
pré d'Apple il coûte un peu plus de 2000
€, j'ai une énorme configuration et vous
allez voir que c'est des choses qu'on va
retrouver alors l'ultra grand-angle je
l'ai fait en photo de nuit mais très
clairement on va venir éviter c'est pas
fait pour venir zoomer un peu mais c'est
pareil on aura sensiblement la même
chose voyez ça typiquement dans le ciel
c'est pas normal donc il y a des choses
qui ne vont pas dans la photo de nuit
pour autant à certains moments où il
faut dire des choses qui sont vraiment
belles regardez là comme c'est beau là
c'est profondeur que j'ai ici avec la
lumière on plonge directement dans le
tunnel je trouve ça vraiment magnifique
il peut venir zoomer également vous
voyez même en zoomant la qualité reste
là on va éviter d'aller trop loin mais
c'est quand même vachement bien regardez
là regardez
maîtriser donc vous voyez il y a des
moments certains cas de figure où il va
avoir un petit peu plus de mal peut-être
un problème au niveau de l'optique j'en
sais rien et ça va être plus compliqué
mais la plupart du temps on sort des
photos qui sont sympas des photos de
bonne qualité photo de nuit également
ici ça fonctionne les lumières c'est
très bien c'est maîtriser c'est joli
donc on arrive à faire des choses même
en nombre avec du détail là si vous
regardez on peut dire un peu on a du
détail dans le tissu qu'on récupère donc
c'est très très très très joli donc dans
l'ensemble je l'aime bien au niveau de
la photo nuit mais il y a deux trois
petits trucs il va falloir finir
corriger bon et là il y avait pas
beaucoup de lumière donc c'est normal ça
c'est pareil j'ai shooté dans un endroit
qui s'appelle l'effet Mera c'est un
restaurant éphémère un côté un peu
aquarium c'est super joli en faible
luminosité ça fonctionne très bien je
vous montre maintenant ce que ça raconte
du côté des fichiers RAW lorsque vous
voulez faire des photos en haute
définition ici en haut il faut venir
activer le petit mode RAW en haut à
droite sauf que si vous regardez vous
vous l'aurez pas donc il faut venir
l'activer vous venez dans vos réglages
et dans vos réglages vous allez dans
appareil photo et dans appareil photo
vous allez jusqu'à format et dans Format
vous venez activer Apple proro parce que
si vous l'activez pas et bien vous
l'aurez pas voyez il a disparu donc vous
allez ici vous activez Apple proro et là
vous avez deux possibilités soit en 12
mégapixels et vous voyez que vous aurez
des fichiers qui sont plus petits de 25
Mo soit en 48 mégapixels 75 Mo mais vous
aurez beaucoup plus d'informations comme
ça ensuite vous pouvez venir là
directement activer le rot pour venir
prendre des photos directement en mode
rose ça c'est plutôt pas mal alors on va
venir chercher un petit fichier lequel
on va s'éviter on va se mettre celle-là
je trouve ça assez sympa alors regardez
c'est des DNG des fichiers qui sont
assez gros parce que si vous regardez on
est quand même sur des fichiers qui font
60 70 mégas donc fichier où il y a
beaucoup d'informations dedans et où on
peut venir travailler alors j'arrive
comme ça c'est très sombre et regarder
lorsque je viens pousser hop là je
récupère mon ciel est cramé donc là
c'est un peu le bazar alors attendez on
va venir juste travailler très
rapidement comme ça je trouve ça pas
trop saturé je vais venir monter un
petit peu je pousse ça hop ma
température de couleur je viens baisser
légèrement et ensuite je viens ici je
viens sélectionner le ciel je vois que
mon ciel est cramé et je peux venir
m'amuser directement ici à baisser les
hautes lumières pour récupérer mon ciel
voilà on va carrément baisser l'expo
vous voyez c'est marrant parce qu'il y a
un côté où on a vraiment les les nuages
bleu de l'autre côté on est vraiment
très très blanc cramé on vient vraiment
faire gaffe au niveau des hautes
lumières pour récupérer un peu de un peu
de matière casser un peu à température
de couleur et ce côté bleuté je trouve
ça très joli et on peut jouer aussi un
peu sur les noirs très légèrement comme
ça bon on se fait un truc vraiment à la
va-vite histoire de voir ce qu'on peut
réussir à faire ce qu'on peut venir
éditer comme ça moi je voudrais ajouter
un peu de texture je trouve ça manque un
peu de texture voilà vous voyez un peu
de texture on va jouer sur la clarté
quand même moi un truc que j'adore c'est
le bleu donc j'ai toujours ajouté un peu
de bleu dans mes photos pas trop un tout
petit peu de bleu bon là une fois de
plus c'est vraiment à l'arrache il y a
légèrement la décontracté et voyez on
arrive quand même à travailler des
choses qui sont assez intéressantes et
je vous montre hein c'est-à-dire qu'on
part quand même de là d'une photo on va
globalement pas grand chose et on
revient ensuite ici et on peut venir
bosser donc ça c'est cool parce qu'on a
quand même vachement d'informations dans
ces fichiers RAW alors on s'en prend une
autre rapidement pour regarder de la
même manière ici c'est de là elle
m'intéressait aussi également vous voyez
j'ai le soleil en haut donc très
rapidement hop là je vais me casser un
peu les noirs on va jouer un peu sur les
ombres on va se resaturer un peu tout ça
récupérer de la couleur donc on a de la
formation vous voyez au niveau de la
couleur ça se ressentir quand même
vachement attention
température de couleur on va venir
casser un petit peu l'histoire on va
venir ensuite corriger un peu le ciel
hop on va baisser un peu l'exposition
casser les hautes lumières modifier un
peu la température de couleur donc ça
c'est intéressant parce que les fichiers
ils sont quand même vachement bon
rajouter un peu de matière très
légèrement de clarté et après tu peux
venir zoomer un peu dans mon image en
fonction de l'endroit où je vais venir à
aller de ce que je vais venir faire donc
là on sera un truc très très rapidement
mais le truc qui est intéressant c'est
de voir que ces fichiers rouges je
trouve quand même pas mal on peut venir
bosser dessus alors après on peut faire
beaucoup de choses là c'est vraiment
histoire de commencer un peu à se marrer
mais bon il y a de la formation donc ça
c'est cool mais il y a notre mode qui
est super intéressant et que vient de
lancer Apple c'est le mode action cam
c'est-à-dire que vous allez avoir une
stabilisation et l'idée c'est de vous
proposer une expérience sensiblement
similaire à une caméra d'action
sensiblement similaire
pour venir tester ce mode action cam je
vous emmène dans un spot que j'aime bien
c'est au niveau du bon Alexandre 3 c'est
cabossé tous les côtés ça saute c'est la
galère absolue donc
là ici vous avez un truc qui se tient
pas mal mais juste là-bas vous avez des
pavés donc n'oubliez pas qu'avec le mode
action vous pouvez filmer uniquement en
2,8 quarts et pas de 4K 24 30 ou 60
images par seconde ça il faut vraiment
le savoir on va venir faire un truc on
va venir mettre l'iPhone en mode action
en face de la nouvelle Gopro Hero 11
black pour voir si et bien la
stabilisation est vraiment là si c'est
smooth par rapport à une GoPro donc là
ici on a la GoPro ici on a l'iPhone on y
va on se met en vélo
ça bouge de ouf c'est hyper dur à faire
parce que je les tiens à toutes les deux
dans une main et je vais essayer de ne
pas tout casser
[Musique]
et maintenant on fait la même chose mais
caméra pointée vers moi il y a un bus
qui arrive en face pratique
[Musique]
soyons clairs ici l'iPhone n'est pas une
GoPro on n'ira pas aussi loin mais par
contre je trouve qu'elle s'en sort bien
il est évident qu'avec la Gopro Hero 11
black GoPro à une expérience est quand
même beaucoup plus poussée que ce que
propose Apple ici d'autant plus que sur
l'iPhone vous êtes uniquement en 2,8k
vous n'êtes pas en 4K donc on va pas
aller aussi loin en termes de qualité
mais par contre je trouve que
l'expérience reste quand même assez
smooth je viens vraiment chercher le
bordel je me mets sur des pavés qui
bougent énormément globalement vous
allez pas faire ça donc si vous voulez
quand même utiliser comme une caméra
d'action vous pourrez ça reste un iPhone
ce n'est pas une GoPro mais je trouve
qu'il y a un côté un peu passe partout
polyvalence qui est extrêmement
intéressant je ne doute pas que
peut-être l'année prochaine sur l'iPhone
15 Pro 15 pro max on aurait peut-être
allé savoir un mode action en 4K
pourquoi pas si ils nous mettent de la
8k globalement ça pour arriver qu'on se
retrouve de la 8k et un mode action en
4K allez savoir en tout cas le résultat
est correct mais si vous voulez vraiment
une caméra d'action préférée la Gopro
Hero 11 black au moins si vous la faites
tomber et que elle prend des chutes avec
mieux se passer qu'un Iphone a 1500
balles quand même alors regardez je vous
montre j'ai également filmé avec le mode
cinématique et j'ai vu des choses assez
intéressantes regardez si vous regardez
bien là vous voyez vous allez voir que
mon visage bon normalement mon visage
est net et ici les espèces de type
boucle de ma veste elles sont
complètement floues et ce qui est super
intéressant c'est lorsqu'on croise des
gens et que je fais le point sur les
gens vous allez voir que les boucles
deviennent nettes et qu'on visage
devient flou vous voyez là les boucles
sont nettes le monsieur derrière et net
il est suivi par le mode cinématique qui
marche bien et mes boucles deviennent
nettes c'est très très bizarre et
lorsque ça revient sur moi mais boucles
vont redevenir floues c'est complètement
logiciel bien évidemment tout ça mais
voyez je pense qu'il y a des fois des
petites défauts d'interprétation alors
là je vais vraiment chercher la petite
bête parce que j'aime bien ce système je
trouve bien le mode cinématique marche
bien et cette année en plus il est
arrivé en 4K donc que demander le mieux
la dernière je trouvais bien mes gadgets
parce que 1080p mais là on peut aller
plus loin en termes de création et on va
regarder sur différentes parties là vous
voyez c'est pareil même système hop je
vais aller sur les gens derrière ça va
sur eux c'est pratique je suis flou mais
books sont net allez savoir pourquoi et
on continue comme ça donc je trouve ça
vachement bien quand même ça marche
vraiment vraiment bien et pour tous ceux
qui louper comment marche le mode
cinématique et bien vous venez repérer
quelqu'un regarder on va s'avancer par
là ça me propose la personne donc là
quand elle est comme ça vous voyez je
peux appuyer ça me fait un verrouillage
du suivi et j'appuie sur le site sur
d'autres personnes et ça me suit les
autres personnes vous ne régler
l'ouverture ici avec le petit F ça va
moduler votre flou et vous venez
paramétrer ça comme ça directement
regardez hop là je récupère la personne
devant ça me fait un fou d'ailleurs ça
reconnait un peu tout le monde donc il y
a un truc qui est très très malin alors
ça c'est le mode cinématique on l'avait
déjà vu l'année dernière il y a pas très
grande révolution cette année mais le
fait d'avoir en 4K c'est bien ça marche
bien donc voilà c'est très convenable et
si vous voulez aller plus loin au niveau
de votre processus de création avec le
mode cinématique vous êtes quoi faire
alors il y a un autre élément sur lequel
l'iPhone est très très bon c'est la
vidéo personnellement j'utilise un
iPhone en tant que smartphone au
quotidien pourquoi parce que ayant un
tremblement essentiel c'est très bien
d'avoir un smartphone extrêmement
stabilisé et avec une super expérience
logicielle et en plus une très bonne
caméra et le truc qui est intéressant et
notamment je vais penser par exemple au
story Instagram comme ici vous avez une
application qui est développée pour un
seul matériel c'est-à-dire un iPhone on
va pas avoir le même problème qu'on peut
avoir ici sur Android avec une
application Instagram et plein de
smartphone derrière donc des fois le
résultat qui peuvent varier dans un
smartphone à l’autre ici tout est
maîtrisé c'est la même chaîne qui est
maîtrisée par Apple donc ça fonctionne
très très bien le résultat en vidéo est
très bon smartphone très stabilisé mais
je voulais vous montrer la vidéo de nuit
parce que ça rejoint vraiment ce qu'on
voyait par rapport à la photo de nuit
tout à l'heure regardez à savoir que là
je suis en vélo donc c'est stabilisé ça
me va bien mais je retrouve une fois de
plus ce problème de d'artefact sur mon
écran à cause des lumières et en vidéo
c'est pareil c'est c'est extrêmement
problématique donc l'iPhone 14 pro max
reste un bon smartphone un bon
photophone on vogue de jour ça
fonctionne bien il y a absolument aucun
problème il est très polyvalent ça c'est
un truc qui est extrêmement intéressant
on voit qu'on peut l'utiliser sur de
l'usage familier l'usage courant mais
également pousser un petit peu les
limites pour arriver sur un usage plus
professionnel même si on n'est pas non
plus sur un boîtier professionnel on
s'en doutera mais on voit qu'en photo on
peut aller plus loin avec des fichiers
rock sur le bonne qualité on voit qu'on
a des modes qui sont différents on peut
venir filmer en province bon je voulais
pas montrer parce qu'on est moins dans
l'usage grand public on a le mode
cinématique qui est là qui est
intéressant on a le mode action qui est
là si vous voulez courir vous jeter un
peu de tous les côtés ou filmer
quelqu'un qui qui court donc si on est
créatif on veut faire un court-métrage
qu'on veut travailler qu'on avoir une
palette très large au niveau de la
création vidéo et bien vous avez un
smartphone qui est très bien qui est
très complet maintenant il reste des
choses à venir encore améliorer à venir
corriger notamment au niveau des photos
et de vidéos de nuit parce que bien
qu'ayant un capteur de 48 mégapixels
probablement des petits réglages à faire
encore au niveau de l'optique et qui
font que des fois on a des super
fichiers on a de très très belles images
et parfois il se passe encore des choses
qui sont un peu mystérieuses et pas
complètement parfaites alors c'est
normal il restera toujours des choses à
venir améliorer mais on se dirait
qu'avec un smartphone à plus de 1000
euros on s'attend à avoir une copie
parfaite elle est pas parfaite mais elle
est pas loin de l'être et après on peut
venir faire également de la macro bon
alors la macro c'est vraiment pour se
marrer je vous montre parce que
personnellement la macro sur smartphone
c'est pas trop mon truc ça reste très
gadget donc je passe très rapidement
dessus on peut venir voilà se faire
plaisir si on le souhaite bon ok
pourquoi pas mais l'iPhone c'est
également un smartphone ça on s'en
doutera c'est pas uniquement une caméra
et pas seulement un appareil photo c'est
un smartphone avec des usages qui sont
super intéressants c'est à dire du
multimédia regarder des films des séries
du gaming il y a un truc qui est très
bien et qui marche toujours très bien
chez les iPhone c'est la partie audio
regardez là je le pousse à fond
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça dépendra de ce que vous voulez ça va
dépendre ce que vous voulez en terme de
photos ça va dépendre de pas mal de
choses notamment du processeur qui est
un petit peu différent mais le prix
n'est également donc à vous de voir
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en mode
dans les commentaires personnellement si
on pose la question faut-il acheter un
iphone 14 je vous dirai acheter un
iphone 13 si on me demande faut-il
acheter un iphone 14 pro max je vous
dirai si vous n'en avez pas si vous avez
un smartphone un peu ancien et qu'il est
temps de le changer vous pouvez aller
sur l'iPhone 14 pro max dès lors que
vous avez les finances parce qu'il reste
quand même relativement cher mais c'est
un bel objet qui est très complet qui
est très polyvalent qui a une super
dalle très lumineuse qui a plein de
belles options qui ont plus de ça elle
mérite d'avoir l'expérience iOS et ça
c'est uniquement sur les iPhone
d'ailleurs je vous ai fait plusieurs
vidéos pour vous parler d'ioss de les
deux astuces donc si vous ne les avez
pas vu aller jeter un coup d'oeil parce
que vous allez voir elles sont super
intéressantes et on découvre plein de
choses c'est très chouette cet iPhone
j'aime beaucoup je vais continuer à
l'utiliser mais voyez je pense qu'il y a
encore des marges de manoeuvre pour le
faire évoluer pour arriver sur un iPhone
qui serait pas parfait parce que aucun
produit n'est parfait mais par rapport à
ce que je vois sur la photo et la vidéo
de nuit je reviens là-dessus si je
regarde par rapport à la night tography
une éthologie je sais jamais c'est la
lithographie au niveau du S22 ultra je
trouve que ça sortait mieux voilà donc à
vous de voir dans quel clan vous êtes
qu'est-ce que vous préférez comme
appareil parce que au-delà de la
meilleure qualité photo et aussi toute
l'expérience logicielle et c'est aussi
là dessus que Apple vient tirer son
épingle du jeu dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez vous comment vous le trouvez cet
iPhone 14 pro 14 pro max et est-ce qu'il
y a un iPhone 14 qui pourrait vous
intéresser cette année si vous dites le
moi en bas dans les commentaires et puis
s'il vous intéresse je vous mets le lien
en bas dans la description vous pouvez
cliquer dessus dites-moi tout ça et puis
on se retrouve très vite pour continuer
à parler d'Apple mais pas que d'Apple et
pas d'autres choses voilà c'est chouette
je vous embrasse à bientôt prenez soin
de vous Ciao
[Musique]